[Music]
hey
you guys and he did it again
all the time hey you guys it's tuesday
here we are talking about another movie
yeah man i'm not feeling good i'm still
not feeling i'm not coughing but
uh my nose just feels like a [ __ ]
forest fire
smells like [ __ ] rotten forest fire
it's terrible
i feel light-headed and [ __ ] weak and
it's not good when i feel weak
he gets he gets real fussy and crazy
i still want to make that i'm getting
fussy sure damn
[ __ ] i can't escape it i'm such an
[ __ ] i know
jesus you know you know what it is jesus
christ jesus christ
yeah i just hope i feel good for
tomorrow for the [ __ ] party
the party's dreaming party stream we
already and we have we already have like
a really good topic to talk about like
i mean you know just a topic to talk
about to jump off on
yeah um you know it's it actually has to
do with a movie that we watched but it
was based on a real yeah i think
i think uh i think louie sent me the
movie hernandez sent this movie it's
called pain again
yeah yeah yeah and we had never seen it
actually
actually i had never even heard of it it
came out in 2013. [ __ ] was a
masterpiece
it was [ __ ] clear i [ __ ] love that
we were just like screaming with
laughter a lot like watching it
and it's based on a true case that
happened in miami back in the 90s
and it's just like the movie like
you can't make the [ __ ] up you just
can't i mean it's the most florida it's
great
ever but yeah so we're gonna that'll be
our jumping off point like for the
party show tomorrow night just because
it was like [ __ ]
funny you guys haven't seen that movie
see pain and gain when we talk about it
tomorrow all right yeah
uh it's got uh uh [ __ ] the rocks in
it
yeah god [ __ ] mark mark wahlberg's in
it
ed harris is in it a little bit and then
what's that guy's name
[ __ ] man now i can't remember [ __ ]
we'll figure it out before yeah because
i want to research the real case
yeah but it but it's not like one of his
big but like
200 bajillion dollar ones it's like a
small budget one that he made well
relatively small about it um also i
wanted to say too i forgot to mention
this yesterday because
louie the senate it wasn't louis the
senate okay maybe it was michael
i don't know i forgot we have to go back
and see because i feel like louie
michael and sophie
are usually who sends us the movies okay
so sometimes i feel bad but sometimes
because i write it down but then
sometimes my notes get off the steel
book edition of pain and gain and
uh and uh [ __ ] um death wish
death wish yeah at the same time that
might think yeah that's right yeah
that might have been michael though
maybe it was michael now that i'm
thinking about it
yeah i get i get them confused sometimes
i get everybody confused i got did i
also get the rambo at the same time i
don't think so i think louie sent me a
rambo well the rambo just came like a
little while ago
like first blood i mean yeah yeah
um but yeah you're gonna you're gonna
die my head's all [ __ ] unclear we're
talking about this movie here
well i wanted to say before before we
started on that a little bit
i forgot to mention this yesterday but
because some i know some of you people
had asked us about um
beijing because she had to go back to
her little vet appointment or a little
follow-up
because of um you know her little liver
issue
she was like real sick and everything
yeah and uh she had her follow-up
appointment and guess what
she's perfectly fine yeah blood work
came back great her [ __ ] liver
recovered so that's good
yeah mackie that's his name anthony
mackie yeah there you go there you go
he was knocking it out of the [ __ ]
park man anthony mackie
and uh kind of reminds me of a young
eddie murphy
he's [ __ ] great in it and uh about a
bunch of [ __ ]
muscle heads at a gym who uh decide to
[ __ ]
become kidnappers and it doesn't go too
well
it's a it's a true crime
comedy adventure action movie it's the
most ridiculous
[ __ ] thing you have ever seen and
there's a bunch of extras on the blu-ray
that talk about the actual case and
how close this movie is to the actual
case
they were doing [ __ ] some of the [ __ ]
was never did some [ __ ] up [ __ ] but it
was so funny because they were such
idiots that they said even like the
even law enforcement was laughing and
the court recorders were kind of
laughing at the stupid [ __ ] they were
doing
yeah because this [ __ ] is like
unbelievable they were totally [ __ ]
tall if you didn't know like about the
actual case you would just be like how
are these people even
yeah it's like how do they even remember
how to breathe these days are like
really really stupid it's kind of like
on par with like the tiger king
it's that crazy it might even be crazier
it's crazy
actually yeah um but yeah oh so a couple
people said
were uh saying yay about beijing yeah
it's like it's weird because when she
first went
and they were like well her liver is
like really they said it was like
so small you could like barely see it
like it was so i don't know if it was
like infected or something like that but
when she went back they said it looks
totally fine now because she was on
all that medication for it for like a
month or however long it was
they think that maybe um that she had
some kind of liver infection from eating
lizards
yeah because i guess you can get that
sometimes if you eat too much lizards
carrot lizard guts carry some [ __ ] or
they carry some stuff that isn't really
good for cats
and you know it's i imagine that she
probably ate something i know i saw some
half eaten lizards
out in the back before yeah i know she
ate some lizards that's a long time
among other things yeah
um and yeah that that might have gotten
earlier but thankfully the
medication fixed it and they said she's
perfectly perfectly healthy so i was
very very relieved to hear that
and like i said i knew some people had
asked about it so i forgot to so i think
that was yesterday
yeah yeah but if you like joe exotic and
that [ __ ] you
you'd like this it's in a different
direction
got the [ __ ] rock mark wahlberg and
[ __ ] you know what's
[ __ ] you just told me what his name was
yeah i gotta remember that mackey
mackey that's right yeah and [ __ ]
they just knock it out of the park and
then the dude
the dude that they uh i forgot the name
of that actor too the guy who played the
dude that they captured
he was [ __ ] he did a good job tony
shalhoub yeah
the dude from monk well among other
things he's been in like zillions of
things
that's a good movie but yeah and this is
a very unique
uh role for the rock he plays a [ __ ]
christian
but he's like save it for tomorrow yeah
we're not gonna have anything to talk
about as far as parts yeah like that's
ever happened
but yeah so um so everyone's happy about
beijing yeah beijing who uh
who's so in love with sophie yeah that
yeah
i i've never seen a cat do that well
i've seen other cats do that
[ __ ] hug sophie yeah she like ran as
soon as sophie got there like we brought
her from the airport
and basically jumped up on the yeah on
the bar stool
yeah and was like because she remembered
her
i remember you i remember you it was the
craziest thing yeah i've never seen her
do that
no never seen her usually when we try to
pet her she just goes
don't touch me she loves sophie though
sometimes like sometimes if she's real
lonely like
i'll be in here in the off she'll come
and she'll sit in my lap for a little
while and just sit there and hang out
but i've she's never hugged me before
though yeah so yeah that was like crazy
she was like climbing up her legs and i
was like
like she was like she was made of catnip
yeah
i was surprised she remembered sophie i
remember you
it was the funniest [ __ ] i wish like
it was just so [ __ ] funny i just
never saw that happen before
all right so the movie that we're
talking about today which you could be
forgiven for thinking we were talking
about that other movie but like i said
we're gonna wait till tomorrow to talk
about that
um is from 2019 and this is a movie
called come to daddy
now i had been wanting to see this for a
while because i kept seeing it like on
all these other people's lists and it
sounded like
funny like it's a horror comedy like a
black comedy kind of
um because it's real violent but it also
has like a really like
weird sense of humor um so i was like
that sounds like that sounds like my cup
of tea these guys committed some
horrible [ __ ] crimes but
the movie was the tone of the movie they
they did it just right
they talked about the the tone had to be
just perfect
you're still talking about the other oh
that's right
i thought you were took me down on this
one yeah i'm sick
no i said we have to save that one for
tomorrow
[ __ ] it i ain't saying anything well i
just wanted to get it back on the track
you know
that's all i thought you wanted to get
back to talking about that one
no because i no i i just said we have to
save that for tomorrow
my head's kind of [ __ ] cloudy yeah
you talk about this
this one's good too i mean it was all
right um
it had that dude from elijah wood
elijah what is it yeah from [ __ ]
lord of the rings man i never really i
never saw a lord of the rings i
i i got part way through the first one
and those [ __ ]
golem things the [ __ ] hobbit things
were looking at each other like hobbit
and gollum are two different yeah you
know
those [ __ ] those [ __ ] gandalf
things were [ __ ] looking at each
other
all things like they were gonna [ __ ]
each other and i was just like man i
can't watch this
too much goddamn eye contact between
these little digits
and so i couldn't finish that [ __ ]
yeah that's nice
i was like get a [ __ ] room
[Laughter]
doesn't last like that unless shit's
gonna fall they're not
they're not humans they're hobbits maybe
maybe shit's different with hobbits i
don't know
but uh yes i said it was obvious
but yeah so gandalfs i was calling them
gandalf gandalfs
that's what i was [ __ ] thinking
that's the dark crystal
that's jim henson property
he's ripping yeah [ __ ] off oh my god the
little gandalfs
and that [ __ ] saying i don't have any
[ __ ] respect
i don't have anything i don't have any
respect for that
every every day you get closer to old
man yells at cloud
you [ __ ] tell my god i'm laughing so
hard that my eyes are starting to water
so if you see like uh mascara and [ __ ]
come runners i'm not crying i'm just
like laughing so hard
yeah so now that we went off on that
whole day
everything's falling apart anyways
i'm ready for some new [ __ ]
okay so yeah okay so this movie like i
said i had seen a lot of people
recommend it so i really wanted to see
it now this
movie is the same uh yes
you make me laugh and i was like my eyes
are watering um
it's the same production company i think
that like the dudes uh
the director's name is aunt timpson and
the writer's name is toby harvard i
think
they're both from new zealand and i
think this is the same
writer director producer team that did
like some other
kind of well-regarded uh kiwi horror
like housebound which was really good if
you guys shouldn't see that i think they
did turbo kid which you love so much
yeah uh deathgasm which is also really
good and um
the greasy strangler which i feel like i
have to see but i haven't seen it yet i
have seen the other three that i just
mentioned but i haven't seen the greasy
strangler yet but this is like the same
team
that uh that came up with that so
basically the story and
oh it's gonna be really really hard to
talk about this movie without
spoiling anything because i think what i
liked best about this movie was not
having any [ __ ] idea of what the hell
is going on where it was going
yeah because i did because i thought it
was like a paranormal horror movie
that's the way it comes off at first
sort yeah it's like
it's weird but yeah but i liked that i
liked that it
that it didn't really give anything away
like you never really knew what
direction it was gonna go
is this a haunted house or what the [ __ ]
is up with this is what the hell's going
on here
it was good it was i liked it i like
it's it's very um like i said it's real
violent like like i said it's it's um
you know uh barbecue fork in the
testicles multiple times violent like in
a close-up
um you know people getting stabbed in
the brain [ __ ] like that so it's so it's
pretty gory
and we're pretty violent um but it also
has this very very strange
sense of humor which i really dug like a
lot of
it just has like this really bizarre
sense of humor yeah
here's the setup this dude is just
soy ass [ __ ] just victor says what
platform is this on we watched it on
amazon prime yeah
amazon amazon prime was free wouldn't it
it was free yeah yeah yeah we didn't
have to pay to rent it
yeah if you got amazon prime you can see
it you can watch it for free
this dude he is just soy as [ __ ] where'd
he come from was it new york or l.a or
something
um yeah i think he was from uh beverly
hills
well he had grown up with his mom and he
was kind of um
he he was very privileged so they had
grown up in a mansion
just wearing just just his clothes and
everything and he's all with this crazy
haircut
yeah what was that all the time this is
non-binary is what they call it
i think that's what they call it no i'm
not where you're neither male or female
we've been called back in a day we'd
call that [ __ ] metrosexual
all right back in the day but uh
he shows up to to his dad's house his
dad's got this [ __ ] badass
man [ __ ] house a man house
as opposed to a woman house well you
have to look like a [ __ ] ufo you got
to see this [ __ ] you got to see the [ __ ]
yeah i think it's supposed to be in
oregon yeah it's on a huge lake
with all these [ __ ] mountains and
there's nothing else around yeah and
it's got
[ __ ] like a right it's the main like
[ __ ]
living room is a bar and it's round and
it's got a [ __ ] i wish my living room
was up yeah
glass windows and it's just a damn
lounge like a bar and [ __ ] you know what
i mean everything's wood colored and
then it's got all the
looks kind of like like i
don't know i don't know it just looks
like a man cave you know he's living on
his [ __ ]
james bond man cave and
he goes there to meet his dad his dad
left him when he was a kid
when he was five and then this but
suddenly 30 years later
he's his dad has supposedly sent him a
letter
saying hey come visit me and he's like
okay here i am but then the dad seems
really
she shows up and the dad's this [ __ ]
skeletal
all drunk tough evil [ __ ]
i'm like what the hell is this all about
what the [ __ ] going on
yeah you're like
one thing leads to another you know yeah
we can't oh it's it's really really hard
because it's like
it sounds like we're not talking much
about it because you can't spoil it
because you can't spoil it because like
i said
i really i had no idea where this was
going like so the whole time i'm
watching it going
what the f okay and you're like okay
well [ __ ] now what
you know what i mean like he doesn't
know what it is what is this [ __ ] is he
trying to
make up with his son is he trying to
toughen his son up what the hell is the
problem
yeah it's like is everything is set up
is the [ __ ] haunted is the [ __ ] you like
you really don't know like what direct
and
and it went into directions i totally
did not expect
it almost started to go a little bit in
the direction of tusk
i thought it was going to go on the
direction you know you were not the only
person that has compared it to that
i was watching another review of it
earlier i can't remember who it was that
was reviewing it but they said the same
thing it gave them that kind of vibe
yeah so that yeah um yeah it did have
that similar kind of vibe to not as
weird
um as tusk but it was pretty weird and
it did have like a really weird like
sense of humor but like a really dark
sense of humor which i like that kind of
thing
it's worth seeing yeah if you like tusk
you'd probably dig it and like i said if
you liked
um you know greasy strangler or turbo
kid or um
you know or housebound uh if you guys
have seen housebound that was also
really good too
um you would probably dig this as well
and like i said i fairly bad that i
can't
go too much into it because there's like
so much i wanted to talk about
but it's like once it gets to a certain
point
that's not really that far into the
movie you can't really spoil it because
like something significant happens and
then like all this other crazy [ __ ] like
spins off from that and it's like i
don't really want to say like what that
significant thing is
turns out nothing is that nothing is
what it appears to be
and you're not giving all the
information and it's just
you know well that's the way it always
is yeah tammy said i have to agree the
best part of the movie is the twist yes
yeah cause i just didn't have any idea
where this was going gotta say though
uh nice to see martin donovan again i
haven't seen him in a while i was i got
really um
i really like him as an actor i got a
nimble watching all his [ __ ]
hal hartley movies back from back in the
90s do you guys remember those
maybe i'm the only person that likes
like amateur and uh
simple men and uh henry fool and all
those kind of movies
[ __ ] was martin donovan and henry full i
can't remember but um
but yeah so he's in it too yeah but um
are you gonna are you gonna live or no
no eventually i'll die eventually but
for now i guess i'll live don't die on
the show
[Laughter]
just my energy level's low yeah maybe we
should wrap it up so you have
more so you have more energy for
tomorrow's party [ __ ]
yeah i need at least another day of
sleep yeah you should probably rest some
more
yeah it's really weird because i felt a
little bit crappy yesterday like i said
i had
like the [ __ ] off like a fever like my
just my face was hot and i had a little
bit of cough like i had needed a few
cough drops and stuff
but today i feel pretty normal yeah i
didn't get a grip on you i was like i
even went out and did my
did my hike with my big heavy backpack
and i was like man i feel pretty good
yeah for some reason you know sorry i'm
not rubbing it in or anything i'm just
saying
i can't [ __ ] work out can't work out
or do anything
so just gonna sit here and wait till it
passes yeah just like i said you gotta
rest and
yeah just you know eat what you can eat
because i know everything
like tastes bad tastes terrible huh but
we had some soup earlier and you said
that tasted all right
yeah i said just eat like kind of mild
flavored things yeah
cause he could you couldn't even eat
like bacon or anything like that the
other day like you made some bacon and
it's like it just that tasted like [ __ ]
too yeah
so yeah um but yeah so
uh come to daddy at least on the
somebody said it's on amazon prime in
the uk but you have to pay for it
um but if you have amazon prime in the
u.s then you should be able to watch it
without paying for it because we did not
yeah i'd pay a couple bucks to see it
you know i mean if it was four bucks or
a big three bucks
i actually liked it a lot like i said
and i i just thought it was cool that
you
compared it to tusk because it was just
funny because i was watching it
otherwise she thinks i'm not really
paying attention to the movies
well because you don't seem like you are
sometimes i i look at it and understand
what they're doing is i can look away i
know i know the games that they're
playing
but but totally and concept-wise
it took some from tusk yeah let's say
like i said like i said it was it's not
exactly the same obviously because tusk
is just like way the [ __ ] out there
but they used some of the same
there was just something about it yeah
like tonally it was very similar
as that so yeah mango says it's only a
pound 99.
oh yeah okay yeah i'd watch it oh it's
definitely worth seeing like i said
especially if you like black comedy and
if you like any of those other movies
that i mentioned like that those dudes
from new zealand made
then uh you probably really like it
because yeah i thought it was
i thought it was pretty [ __ ]
hilarious and like i said
the guy getting stabbed with the fork
and the balls i mean you know yeah i
found that very entertaining but you
know how i you know how i
am all right so uh we will be back i'm
gonna let tom take a nap and
yeah try to get better and uh
we will see you guys tomorrow evening at
5 p.m
eastern for our wednesday sidetracks
party stream
we're going to be talking about pain and
gain and the
case behind it and whatever else we feel
like
talking about so uh thanks everybody for
dropping by and we'll
see you guys tomorrow bye